hi my name is Patton Oswalt and I feel
radiant about being Conan O'Brien's
friend you know it's funny there's a
light coming off it really does well I'm
glad you're here I'm glad I'm here and
that's all the time we have all right
thanks a lot uh check me out patent
oswalt.com tour dates coming up thanks I
got five other podcasts to do man I'm
really I'm just doing the promo thing do
you know because the Late Night show
started in 93 I feel like you were on uh
one of those people that came on fairly
early on around I think 94 94 or 95 was
my first
um
my first time and then I used to say I
used to refer to you as just money in
the bank meaning you would come on the
show and I knew that that was a segment
not only did I not have to worry about
it but it was going to be really really
funny and we could do as much time as we
wanted to which is always a gift for
someone like me you can relax I can
relax Patton's here and
um he'll just you would go down these so
many fascinating little wormholes in
your comedy which are very and the way
you paint pictures using words always
delighted me you've got such you've got
great imagery yeah it I always felt um
good about that
[Laughter]
telling time
have you taken a turn you were the first
late night show that I would go and
where you would actually give me insight
into the sausage making of the show oh
you were very when we were off micro
going to commercial you were very open
about a guest that had just been on
where you're like that was pulling teeth
like God they had nothing to say and I
remember I'm not going to name the band
we're I was on one time and a band came
on and was playing it was one of those
early like uh screamo bands and uh and
you just leaned over to me and you went
I hate wisdom Rock and that that is the
category that I assigned there are
certain bands take my hand on that kind
of yes wisdom Rock and and it's always
insulting because it's wisdom Rock from
22 year olds yes like people who've not
had any but they have come down from the
mountain to tell you that and and power
cords and also that way of singing that
sounds like a donkey is preaching yes
and it was always a psych I'm going to
yeah two years from now you'll be
working at a hardware store and
you're giving us this key to the Future
let me tell you how lovely no you don't
you don't need to tell me now he's yeah
let me show you how to mix up that paint
I'll put it in this machine and then
it's going on fabric real first
take my hand and give me that coupon
the hell nuts this week it really was
but that became such a genre for me in
my mind Summer's Here of course summer
is the time for everything fresh let me
list a few fresh air refreshing
vacations and plenty of hellofresh to
laughing up Meals that's where I was
going hello fresh and with Chef crafted
seasonal recipes and new fresh and fit
summer menu hellofresh brings you flavor
right to your door yeah now's the peak
time for summer produce hello fresh make
sure you get all the best picks all
season long delicious fresh meals mmm
we'll make your home the place to be
this summer pre-proportioned ingredients
that help cut down on food waste and
time while step-by-step Instructions
make cooking a breeze not a chore hello
fresh combines quality and convenience
with ingredients making it from the farm
to your door in less than seven days
Sona hello fresh saved your life I don't
know if it saved my life as a cook
you're a disaster on your own but when
Hello fresh is involved it's fantastic I
didn't think that was the case but yeah
I really like hello fresh they sent me
three meals one was a chicken one was a
pork and one was a fish yeah and
fantastic I crushed it yeah and I
remember going to your house once for
dinner before you use hellofresh and you
serve me one meatball on an ice cream
cone yeah no that's not a meal but hello
fresh did is it totally upped your game
congratulations Sona that was a good
meatball uh no I'm not sure that was
meat anyway
go to hellofresh.com Team coco50 and use
code Team Coco 50 for 50 off plus free
shipping that's team coco50
hellofresh.com teamcoco50 for 50 off
plus free shipping America's number one
meal kit the other thing I was
remembering just now as you said it was
there was a different there was other
kind of bands that would come on and I'm
young I'm 31 32 and some of these bands
are very intimidating oh yeah and uh
they'd come on the the show and they've
they've got
they're they're wearing tatters like
tattered leather yeah and they're
they're they've put makeup on that looks
like their eyes are bleeding and it's
just incredibly intense in this song is
them you know screaming and hey hey hey
die and I would go after or go over
afterwards and of course I'm dressed
like an insurance salesman and I would
go and you can see it I'm like 31 32 and
be like oh well you know Murder Mayhem
you go that's we'll take a break we'll
be right back and and in the commercial
break with the the Max Weinberg and the
Seven would start to play
and inevitably the guy would take off
his skull mask and he'd say lean over
and they were invariably from the
Midwest and he'd say hey I just want to
say thank you so much for having us on
it's really an honor uh and such a such
a pleasure and so nice to finally meet
you and I'd be like oh you know and it
turns out like yeah this is their act
this is it's their business and they're
lovely fellows yeah as um blank capatch
has a great line about I don't know if
you know who GiGi Allen was GiGi Allen
was this extreme punk rocker he would
perform naked he would defecate on stage
he would throw his poo at the audience
it was all in the early nights and blank
about yourself is my impression of uh
GiGi Allen before show when I in my
hand I've got five
be ready be ready with my towels
but yeah it's all it is eventually like
Dolly Parton and the guys from Slipknot
could get together and go oh yeah the
Acoustics and the Ryman are crazy we
were trying to get oh I know exactly
like they have all that this is the
stuff I love I love that it's show
business because it doesn't matter
Slipknot is another one of those bands
where I went out there they were I think
they I could be wrong but I think their
first TV appearance was on our show and
I remember it culminated with it wasn't
I'll tell you story about that in a
second go ahead it culminated with the
drummer using his head to like bang
drums that were on either side of his
head I mean it was just absolutely not
an animal from the Muppets yes yeah and
so I went over and they're you know
fully unmasked and just Madness and I
remember coming over and saying Slipknot
and they all gave me a group hug I swear
to God no one had showered in a year and
they've been sweating and so remembered
powerful smell and all these guys
wearing skulls hugging me and then a
minute
hey uh Conan thank you so much I mean
lovely guys yeah yeah thank you so much
and then the guy who like you know with
his who hit his head against two drums
saying no I uh I'm thinking maybe if uh
I might try to teach
I might try Linguistics uh but it was
just I always loved that part I always
love where people are flipping
identities oh I love that well okay so
when Slipknot was the Slipknot was first
on your show that was her first and I
know this because
uh Brian posein called me and said hey
can you I had one of the first tivos for
some reason this is in the infancy of
TiVo he goes could you please record
Conan because I have to work late and I
don't know how to program my VCR and
Anonymous slip knot and I go yeah he
goes I'll come over tomorrow I want to
watch Slipknot because he was a huge
Slipknot fan so I recorded the whole
left I mean I recorded all the episodes
I would just watch them all right and on
that episode you had it was John Glazer
and uh Brian and um
um oh God I'm blanking on his name but
they they came out as the slip nuts yes
you're like we we double booked we
weren't thinking it through might have
been Andy Blitz and it was Andy Blitz
Brian
stack and John Glazier were the slip
nuts and it was a thing where there were
that these vaudevillian guys that would
come out
um and and the whole idea was it was
supposed to be just the worst idea ever
they were like we're the slip nuts and
their whole thing was they have one joke
they had one joke which is we we put
nuts on the floor and we slip on those
knots
we're the slip nuts slip and none nuts
and then clowning around and slipping on
nuts wear the slip nuts slipping on nuts
oops he fell down and then John goes I
slipped on some nuts they repeat the
joke like eight times it's maddening so
anyway Brian comes over to my apartment
intentionally maddening intentionally
maddening so Brian comes over my
apartment and I and I had the whole
shirt so I queued it up to where the
slip nuts come on and I go hey I
recorded uh the slip nuts last night
he's like Slipknot dude but like like
I'm mispronouncing it I'm like I was
well I mean I watched the whole show
it's uh slip nuts it's like slip knot I
go well this is what I recorded dude and
I they came out and he just like stood
there like in silence for a second like
what I'm like dude it's a sketch this
here's something like he got so pissed
off at me because he didn't know that
that's what you guys okay done this is
this makes me so happy and blay you're
gonna remember what this is I hope but
what we did once is a prank is we had
slip nuts come on a couple of times and
it was just inferior I think you know
obviously some people in the crowd got
what we were doing which was being
intentionally stupid but it was so
irritating and then my one of my
favorite things ever is we sent slip
nuts to an actual heavy metal concert
have you seen this play one of the best
pieces of footage yes I've ever seen so
which one was it I I think I'm gonna I
was just about to look that up it might
have been a slipknot's concert they
might have got opened for Slipknot no no
they opened for I I've seen this sketch
okay for Slipknot but you did this whole
story where they have all the slip notes
have broken up one of them joined in
ashram the other one like they did like
this beat now they're back together and
they've like were and they just still do
the same act but they're basically
the backstage guy is like you better get
off as quick as you can like they're
gonna be and I don't know someone got a
great shot ladies and gentlemen slap
dots but they but the crowd just like
slip yeah so they're all going crazy and
then the slip nuts come out and they go
dresses
with bags of peanuts and they get this
moment where the crowd is like yeah
and then every arm just goes down and
you see the anger and it's it's one of
the most hilarious pieces of food and
they do like the slip not slip but not
and they do that in front of the crowd
and they commit to it and then I fell
down something else and the guy
backstage said you better get the
out of here they're gonna kill you yeah
like like not don't just leave the stage
get out of the venue you're dead it was
amazing well and and from what I heard
talking to John Glazer um Slipknot loved
the well they loved the slipknots on the
show they thought it was great yeah and
they're like they have to open for us
okay you're gonna get killed